ah
[Música]
a
cuando neil armstrong pisó la luna china
estaba en la revolución cultural imago
se lamentaba de que no pudiera enviar al
espacio ni siquiera una patata ha pasado
medio siglo y china ahora rivaliza con
eeuu por la primacía espacial y
protagoniza algunas de las misiones más
audaces este año envió una sonda a marte
y dos años atrás había enviado otra a la
cara oculta y más desconocida de la luna
también este año ha enviado a tres
astronautas hacia su inminente estación
espacial para que vayan acondicionándola
para sus futuros ocupantes esa estación
es la historia de una venganza eeuu vetó
la participación china en la estación
espacial internacional y los chinos
humillados decidieron ponerse con la
suya a finales de esta década cuando la
estación espacial internacional se
jubile la única operativa será la china
por lo que muchos astronautas de todo el
mundo están aprendiendo mandarín porque
china ha prometido que será inclusiva y
abierta a todas las nacionales del mundo
o casi todas
la unión europea ha centrado su política
espacial en sobre todo como ser útil en
el día a día de la gente como por
ejemplo en la lucha contra el cambio
climático mejorar la vigilancia de los
campos agrícolas o predecir mejor la
meteorología en los últimos años ha ido
aumentando el presupuesto en los
programas espaciales como copérnico el
programa de observación de la tierra que
envía información a tiempo real a través
de satélite como por ejemplo para
predecir mejor las catástrofes naturales
también está el programa galileo el
sistema de navegación que ayuda por
ejemplo a las aeronaves en sus rutas
todo esto se hace a través de la agencia
espacial europea que investiga y también
forma a futuros astronautas de hecho
también forma parte de misiones y
proyectos como el crudos que contó por
primera vez con un astronauta de la
agencia europea
el viaje al borde del espacio de richard
brandson al dueño de la empresa virgin
galactic se hizo nueve días antes de que
lleve precios el hombre más rico del
mundo también viaje en su propia nave
espacial supersónica por encima de la
atmósfera una competencia entre
millonarios para posicionarse la
industria comercial espacial y ofrecer
en un futuro cercano viajes suborbitales
a clientes dispuestos a pagar entre 200
mil y 300 mil dólares por el paseo al
borde del espacio de echo virgin
galactic ha anunciado que ya tiene 600
personas que han reservado o puestos los
próximos viajes sin embargo la empresa
hará un viaje más de prueba antes de
empezar a ofrecer este servicio frente a
estos viajes se han presentado críticas
de quienes argumentan que este dinero se
debería usar para combatir el cambio
climático y otros problemas en el mundo
antes que ofrecer nuevas formas de
diversión a multimillonarios
[Música]